you're wrong there
[Applause]
vana and Keogh taking time out of their
Dancing with the Stars rehearsal to get
sorted into their Hogwarts house how is
that right partner
vibes are strongly southern off you
can't miss it only fitting on Monday the
Harry Potter star will dance to Hedwig's
theme I feel like it's time for some
Harry Potter magic what can you tell me
it's exactly time for Harry Potter magic
yeah when they said two most memorable
year I was like I don't know what else I
would pick I was such a huge Harry
Potter fan so it was like stepping into
this world that I so adored and was
obsessed with so yeah that was like most
life-changing year ever but Yvonne
Adele's Edie it's actually going to be
emotional for a very personal reason
before Harry Potter I was really I was
quite sick and I Harry Potter books
really helped me through an eating
disorder and the reason I wanted to talk
about it on here is healing for me
that's why it was so special because it
was the only kind of light that I saw in
the world at a very dark time I feel
like those books have been that for a
lot of people absolutely no I met so
many people especially my character Lee
and I get a lot of people writing to me
have been bullied a lot of people who
just struggle to fit in in the world and
just feel like oh she gives them
permission to be themselves and to not
feel ashamed for it how are you going to
take that message and put it into dance
I think there's the hardest part I'm
feeling the pressure every day because I
think that's what the fans are looking
forward to but also I don't want to run
away from her story I need to be very
careful in what I do and how I forgot
this dance was very special to her I
know that this week on Dancing with the
Stars tends to be really emotional
four people are you prepared for that I
already went home last night and had a
little cry I was like oh this is so
intense yeah I don't know if I'm
comfortable having all that attention on
me when I've told this story before it's
like it gets very sensationalized in the
media and they like tell it as like a
fairy tale story we like going from
having this getting Harry Potter and
it's like this those kind of issues
they're never that neat and kind of
sometimes I'm like it upsets me like all
you get Harry Potter on your mental and
this is cured it's like that's very kind
of that's a wrong message and unhealthy
message to send what do you want people
to know I want to tell this story right
so what do you want people to take away
I want people to know that like these
kind of issues they're a fight every day
you're constantly having to choose
between like that the negative voice
that's in your head telling you you're
you you're terrible at everything that
years you suck and then the voice saying
no I can be something I want to say to
any young person struggling with what
what I strolled with I could not be
doing a challenge like this I could not
have gotten through like doing Harry
Potter films if I had continued down
that route so I just want to say that
that there's like once you've put
yourself out there and like believe in
yourself things happen
[Music]
[Applause]